what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves an
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania trailer
John how are you I'm very excited for
this how are you sir I'm doing good we
got our citizen Kang shirts real rejects
exclusive at shopzer edition.com koi
chandro 117 days to land man very
excited oh wow you really counted it's
Kang dude it's Ken yeah King is coming
it's time he's coming all right guys
let's get to it
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing wow he's a real celebrity
helped that that's why we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Kawana wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum realm
goddamn right she is good job
oh no
too late
[Music]
it's gonna be awesome such a different
tone from the other ones
oh that looks beautiful
God damn that looks beautiful
dang
[Music]
beneath ours
there's something I never told you she
slept with King
what you think
let's go
foreign
holy [ __ ]
so
What's it gonna be
[Music]
oh dude yep wow yeah trailer
now before before this played because I
I know I had some people uh message me
like it's out it's out yeah I'm aware
I'm paying attention to checking for the
last four hours yeah
there were people I know that saw like
you saw it at d23 like I heard this
trailer was actually different I hadn't
seen any of that because I didn't go to
d23 I heard this one is definitely
different they had sort of that like
ethereal tone to it especially with
diving into the quantum realm from what
I heard from the previous ones that it
felt like much more harsh and harrowing
when it came to King and they didn't
really capitalize too much on that for
their first debut trailer to go online
but for what we got here I thought it
was actually quite excellent I thought
it was so beautiful to behold and you
know you get the teases of you know uh
Paul Rudd Scott Lang dealing with his
ego trip and the fact that he's on and I
feel like I feel like this is going to
be a humbling experience for him by the
end as someone who thinks he's kind of
Unstoppable by this point and that he
knows better then he's gonna have to go
up against someone like Kang what I'm
really excited for too is Janet's story
because it looks like we're going to be
unpacking her history with the quantum
realm and everything that she dealt with
there because there was obviously such a
fear to going back there other than the
trauma being lost there sounds like
there was a real specific experience
that took place perhaps has some kind of
understanding of who King might possibly
be and of course seeing the culture and
civilization with everyone there I
thought this was a beautiful trailer it
was it was really really beautiful Corey
before you go all deep diving here John
what'd you think I absolutely agree and
I love the transition that the tones go
through because yeah you start out in
this sort of fun happy almost wacky
place with Scott and then you have the
whole crew together you got Cassie and
hope and and the van dynes and all that
stuff and then you're going on this
beautiful looking Adventure across the
yellow brick road I even love the song
choice and the way they interpolate that
and then it gets more and more Sinister
the more you know you see these
different entities and then ultimately
Kang and his forces is revealed I mean
this looks absolutely like something
huge and important and a cool way to
make an Ant-Man movie feel like a really
huge and vital event and uh yeah like I
cannot wait for the imagination that I
hope you know is abundant in this movie
as suggested by this trailer and
especially all the fun different
appearances we will get everyone loves
Bill Murray right now it's it's the time
to have it time to love Bill Murray
right did we catch a motor back to
Howard the Duck Cameo alongside oh God
based on everything we've heard about
that uh
d23ts are combined with this I'm so so
so excited for this movie Cory what'd
you think I love first of all that
Kang's presence is so ominous no matter
what they're able to nail that just him
descending and also that they have the
markings on his face that mirror the
markings on his mask I really like that
but what I'm most interested in is this
does seem to open up an entire world of
possibility for the greater MCU we've
seen the strange esoteric and bold and
Doctor Strange and that's due to Magic
we haven't really seen it due to science
and I really think it's interesting that
when you look at time displacement you
look at the size of something and like
like for example in Civil War when when
giant man appears and he grows he seems
to be moving slow because his sense of
reality and time is going to be
different I'm wondering how they're
going to play around with the time
displacement of the quantum realm their
size versus Kang's perception of time
how they're going to play around with
what time is in this realm what they're
going to play around with what throwing
Quantum realities at others offensively
and defensively how long have those
people been in that City there's so many
things you can kind of open up by
opening up this Quantum realm in this
Quantum world and by adding science and
Magic as they're leading to his Iron
Heart we're gonna see Kang be
theoretically the time side of things
and I do think we're going to start to
see time and Magic combine as we heard
at d23 with the hood and iron heart and
those things so I'm really curious what
this realm connects to the others that
that feel like this look like and I do
think it's one of the most beautiful
trailers I've seen I think the scope of
it and letting these artists have the
time to play in this world this looks
like when I first saw the Guardians of
the Galaxy trailer and I was just oh
overwhelmed by the Kirby of it all by
the scope of the cosmic yeah so that
plus a character we already know as
opposed to the Guardians we had to meet
the Guardians we had to invest in their
world and then their Universe we already
love Paul Rudd so we're just gonna get
to dive in to this world and experience
what this all sets up I could not have
loved that trailer more that's like a
top Marvel trailer for me Janet or Hank
who's gonna die oh Hank's gonna die I'm
going I'm going Janet I think they both
might die I think I think son of a [ __ ]
what if Ant-Man and the WASP represent
those two this time right they pass away
because they're Ant-Man and the WASP
yeah and then they go yeah yeah well I
feel like one thing we're 100 getting
every time we see something with one of
the younger players that we're thinking
joke Avengers Young Avengers but Cassie
already seems like she's already
upsetting Scott with her with her
behaviors and Antics and the path that
she's going down so I feel like we're
getting a pretty direct setup for her
for her to be part of the young
adventures
yeah I think when she leaves this it's
stature I think she might even be
stature when they go into the quantum
realm I could see you know him trying to
identify with his daughter they're not
seeing eye to eye he makes her a costume
or she does it on her own as an actor
Rebellion but I also like that the
opening of this trailer is him not
getting the respect he thinks he
deserves and being called Spider-Man but
then but then at the end the last line
is Ant-Man so it mirrors like oh I don't
want him to know who I am they don't
know who I am there's an interesting
like humbling as well as like a bit of
malice in knowing exactly who he is I
know I love that about it like it seems
like there's going to be a very specific
character Journey for him because I feel
like with even with the last Ant-Man
movie it wasn't really about Scott
laying as much tends to be more about
the you know the van Don family yeah or
the Pam family yeah yeah yeah and and I
feel like this is going to be very much
focused on laying you were talking about
time and and quantum mechanics all those
fun things I'm feeling like there's
gonna be some type of false Victory I
feel by the end where perhaps Our Heroes
I like I don't think Paul Rudd's gonna
die I feel like they'll they'll come out
alive but they're gonna be traumatized
by the end and I feel like that's going
to be setting up something for perhaps
Loki season two I think this has to tie
into Loki season two obviously to the
bigger picture with the Multiverse Saga
with Kang Dynasty and whatnot perhaps we
might see like alternate versions of
other characters in here and then we
will probably see alternate timelines
like we're really gonna explore how time
works here because we had everything
with he who remains and there's been a
lot of theories going around about how
you know the TVA probably is within the
quantum realm itself and that's how he
who remains was able to harness control
and during the multiversal wars and then
create his own version of a sacred
timeline and I think that's a big part
of what we're going to really digest and
understand and I think this will
actually lead Segway in some way into
Loki season two specifically it's
interesting this kicks off this time
alignment I'm wondering how many things
in this world deal with time because you
know phase four had so much multiversal
stuff obviously we're going to keep the
Multiverse stuff because it's all the
Multiverse Saga but this kicking off
phase five this being an early next year
February release I'm really curious how
much timey why me quantum mechanics we
do get going forward plus I love the
contrast here if you hear the d23
footage is all like Avenger if I killed
you before and in here it just ends on
no Ant-Man I know exactly who you are
yeah I mean that's dichotomy between the
uh Spider-Man like the joke I also think
like the darkness of going from levity
to Darkness is also very Ant-Man with
the tone we've established so far I'm
excited to see an Ant-Man movie that
actually feels really important and that
is not disregarded because I like the
Ant-Man movies a lot and and I think
that they kind of get a weird rep as
like they're just kind of whatever well
I think it's a tricky thing is the
character is in Canon scene as whatever
as a joke like it's a self-referential
thing so I feel like the the movie's got
unfortunately stuck with like oh it's
just Ant-Man but like that's supposed to
be humorous and then it became literal
and Peyton Reed's a great director and
he loves the Marvel Universe like Peyton
Reed is one of us I don't know there's a
lot of directors that can give you a
20-minute dissertation on each hero but
he really looks like he he made his
Quantum realm he made what he's always
wanted to see in the comic books on
screen I was dazzled by it yeah I hope
we actually get a really explore that
that group versus you know just like a
scene or two because I imagine that a
lot of that's linked to Janet's past and
who she was probably kicking I mean if
you introduce a Bill Murray character I
imagine that's gonna he's gonna be a
Jeff Goldblum ask maybe he's another one
of the you know a bit larger beings
Allah The Gardener The Collector that he
could be the one in the quantum realm
that watches over that it'd be
interesting if he was one of those
beings and then we've also got the
entire civilization of of you know
aliens and and it looks like you know
Star Wars adjacent people that are
trapped in this realm cat or it's just
or just funny or is this building
he's playing Bill Murray he's just a
cameo all right guys we'll leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
click that Bell tell us what you thought
of the trailer what are your theories
for what's going to take place who do
you think's gonna die all right we'll
talk with you all soon thank you guys
[Music]